on March 2 6 oh I think I was four days
into my mother's my mom passed away if
my mom was here it would be so much
easier at home we've been thrown into
the unknown as a result of this pandemic
a failed part of a lost generation young
people's lives are changing right now
and for years to come
my friends still have the ability to go
and see their friend like socially
distant sin
I can't do that I feel quite lonely I
love the time younger people will bear
the brunt of this in so many economic
ways babies are being born into this new
normal world little ghost baby aren't
you a little lockdown loved by Britain's
young population are being crippled
financially and socially this war feels
like were to skip and straight out of
hood we just want to be young kids who
is talking to you even saying we hear
that this will impact you for years to
come they will forever be known as the
coronavirus generation
in the UK there's about 16 million
people classed as generation said
ranging from those starting out in
primary school right the way up to
graduates and the coronavirus is
impacting them all right now many can't
do exams can't go to high school proms
can't go to university and experience
living there or save up cash by working
a job for many this really is a
childhood to forget hi I'm Alison I'm 16
years old
one day I want to be a professional
football and play for Chelsea FC in
Croydon and across the country young
teenagers like Alex rely on you to
support projects not only through the
loneliness of lock down before their
future - so much of what we talked about
before the pandemic was need to support
youth where people to support the youth
and charity sector but obviously we're
going to be the first to be thrown aside
the entire ecosystem of things that you
encounter in your particularly in your
early life is really important it could
mean the club's that you're all part of
it could be in playing sport all of
these things matter and we simply don't
know that the long-term impact of taking
them away from people on much this ship
so I think I was four days into my marks
my mum passed away at 2 a.m. on the
Friday
I tried to finish my marks my head
wasn't at it my head wasn't trying to
focus on Jesus he's more grieving every
day and just upset and crying I think so
it was hard and then you went straight
into this mad new world this coronavirus
world it was Mother's Day the day before
we went on lockdown and I remember just
grieving over my mum and if my mom was
here it would be so much easier at home
because I've had to adapt my two sisters
trying to live without my mother I live
without a parental figure a lot of the
organizations especially as has helped
me my mother Dave they've shown me
support which I can say grateful find I
know a lot of people don't get that
support cutting funding cut a new scent
is cut a new charity stopping them
enough to do their useful work that they
were doing will have lasting effects
with potential funding cuts to a support
group like this young teenagers like
Alex could be left behind in vulnerable
situations in decades to come we will
look back and say mm-hmm maybe there are
some things we're living through right
now that are a consequence of what
happened during coronavirus only a lot
of time then anxious something kind of
worrying about what's going to happen
after stuck at home unable to work
Bethany took up tarot card reading as a
lock down hobby but no one could have
predicted what lies ahead for university
students like her along with the strikes
they're having a lot of our literature
streaked and we were actually only on
Muni for under five months and I first
you have your news it's quite a big
thing so I do feel like I've just barely
been there really I feel like I started
yesterday I could recite the whole first
day right now I just feel like it was
cut so short I at that point of the day
where I'm feeling pretty low if you're
lying in bed and you've got a zoomcar in
30 minutes you you're just kind of like
do that you feel so bad and guilty for
feeling like this because of all the
stuff that's going on out there
according to young minds a third of
young people say the pandemic made their
mental health
much worse we're going to go back into a
world that's completely different so
that is gonna have a really big impact
on young people absolutely it might
impact the way they create relationships
the way they work it can also you know
affect some of the maybe the
opportunities that they may grasp when
something so chaotic is going on in the
world and when you won't suffer in the
Midianites it's quite difficult to
concentrate on something as many school
is its coursework you know it's nice the
area the house and go somewhere really
play in and can relax such as can I show
you the graduating class of 2020 are
entering some of the most difficult and
volatile periods since the financial
crash and the Great Depression of the
1930s in fact up to two-thirds of
university students applying for
graduate jobs have seen applications
paused or completely scrapped before
anyway it was worrying how you were
kinda gonna get a job no it's just kind
of more so kind of afraid baby but okay
ten things as much so if you're just
starting off now coming out of school or
coming into university the first few
years of your career of really important
like statistically more important than
any other years of your career and
economists have looked back and they've
realized that if someone comes out of
school comes our university doesn't get
a job in the first few years they are
more likely never to get a job during
this pandemic employees under 25 are
about two and a half times as likely to
work in a sector that is now shut down
this will have huge implications for
their futures
hi my name is Yaya I'm 17 and I am
hoping to study drug free with a year
aboard in the shadow of a London estate
the basketball court has been Yaya's
escape during the lockdown
he should be at college taking his
a-levels preparing for a life at
university the uncertainty and not
knowing what you could have come out
with and knowing that it's all gonna
rely on a simple calculate grips that's
the worst part about it I think if those
last four months that really count the
most will do a levels you work those
whole two years in the first year you're
sort of like you know feel free you and
then the second year is when you really
start to grind and go for it it's just
worrying to know that you can't do
anything about your future I mean
like many people Yaya is relying on a
bursary to go to uni one he worked hard
to get because of the the grades that
you get at a level you may not get that
bursary that that you need how much of
an impact will that be to you that have
a huge impact because it was it was
something which was very competitive to
get like just to support myself really
in the university I'd have to work more
you know maybe find a new job but Yaya
already works three jobs to help save
for university and support his family
Kove it is a lot of financial pressure
on my family my mum has to constantly
stay home look after everyone my
brother's being furloughed not making as
much as they could be you're going to
work you're doing nine-to-five like an
adult you're coming back home giving
half of that money to your mum or your
family it just seems strange to be
living that sort of that I don't pursue
any of that I don't good and sort of
missing out on school missing out on
that celebration it's just a little bit
crap really
[Music]
you'd wait at the front door and then
we'd have to tell him we're not we're
not going anywhere we're staying inside
and he'd be really upset by it
[Music]
my name's faith Oliver and I'm the
member of Youth Parliament for Stockport
[Music]
[Music]
those with special education needs it's
been quite a difficult period because
there have been a lot of cuts you know
to a local authority budgets which have
have trickled down and so you haven't
necessarily got quite as resilient a
support structure as you did before and
then on top of that you obviously have
this crisis the virus the lockdown many
children with those needs haven't been
able to go to their to the schools or to
the support structures that they need to
keep them going they say your teens are
the best years of your life but for
faith who has to juggle supporting her
younger brother and her schoolwork the
consequences of this pandemic mean life
is extra hard my boy was very used to
very rigid routines so he gets up at a
certain time he gets ready for school he
eats the same breakfast he sees the same
people every day because we used to be
in able to him to go to school but
because he's in the house full-time it's
gone a lot to me and my sister to make
sure we can care for my brother whilst
everybody in the house does their bit to
make sure everything's still going as it
should be we can always give him
necessarily what somebody from an
outside organization can come in and do
so when those cuts happen I think even
though it'll affect ORS it will affect
my little brother the most
it's Chris right catch-22 chief
executive I I have to run an
organization which no we reach out to
sixty or thousand people a year and
hopefully have some impact on their
lives young people are at the heart of
your organization so do you feel because
of the corona virus pandemic you'll
support fewer in the future yeah that's
money we'll have less money to spend on
reaching the people we're here to to try
and support the people are the most
vulnerable that people are going to
suffer most from this crisis under the
coronavirus Act outlined by the
government in April support for special
educational needs students like faith
younger brother has already been altered
it's still too early to say just how
difficult and brutal this is going to be
but I don't think it's too early to say
that there is going to be bad news and
setbacks in the coming months
[Music]
Generation Y also known as Millennials
were already hugely damaged by the 2008
financial crash and yet they face
another recession from a virus which has
not just claimed lives but also our
economic stability too
normally you have like a recession maybe
every kind of seven eight nine years but
you very rarely get to mammoth
recessions and the financial crisis was
at the time yeah that was supposed to be
a once-in-a-lifetime recession and now
this is going to be even worse right now
even twelve years on from the recession
half of the country's 25 to 34 year olds
have financial debts like loans credit
cards bills and mortgages that is only
set to get worse with another economic
crisis looming what you kind of go home
and think about at just the age of 23
Laura inherited the family business over
a decade later because of this pandemic
she fears it may not survive she grew up
here growing up here I'm taking over the
family business if the business was and
to die as a result of that then yeah I'd
find it very upsetting
we've only actually been a chef for a
total of one day in 40 odd years which
was half a day for Princess Diana's
funeral half a day for my father's you
know CEM that Monday night obviously
when we all tuned in I watch virus's
announcement you must stay at home
making the decision texting all the
staff and saying right the daughter chef
we're gonna have to change things around
you know it's very difficult but it
isn't just her future Nora is worried
about like her father did for her she
was going to pass on the florist
business to her kids it's it's a huge
worry and no are we still going to be
here you've just had a generation you
know millennial generation which has
grown up in the clouds of the financial
crisis now you have another generation
you know some Millennials and some of
the kind of generations below who are
coming into the labor market when again
unemployment is going to be up at those
recession and levels it's it's it is
very concerning growing up in a business
has done me a remarkable world of good
managing money budget in just general
interaction with people you know social
interaction at all of those skills you
don't necessarily learn and you most
certainly don't learn them in school so
not being able to teach my children
those skills that's probably the most
important thing to me actually one of
the great things about the lockdown is
everyone sitting together and eating
together which we do twice a day trying
all sorts of traditional Indian food so
here is the family say hello everyone
it's already really difficult when
you're trying to find a house right now
house price is a really high getting
hold of mortgages it's quite difficult
no no houses new houses to view nothing
that was updated on the housing market
apps a lot of people have hopes that we
might now kind of you know things might
start to improve but now along comes
this and it's quite possible that banks
might be more reluctant to lend so it
might be more difficult to get hold of
mortgages since 2008 the average age of
someone buying their first
has increased from 30 to 33 and the
economic impacts of this pandemic could
see that average age cries Sayid may
only be 23 but he wants to get his foot
in the housing ladder like many
Millennials well this is the house the
house that we were hoping to buy my
name's Sayid I'm 23 and I was hoping to
buy this house instead he is living at
home with his family I share a room with
my crown master trying to keep my
grandma's radio off for four hours when
she wants to listen to her music is
gonna be quite difficult away from his
wife just months after they got married
two meters away here it's not being them
certainly not being easy whilst focusing
on saving for a house they simply can't
afford to rent so this this this house
behind us is one that I had seen on the
market about two weeks before the
lockdown happened we've put an offer in
and then the bank's decided that they
weren't going to lend to just 5%
deposits anymore you see those who are
privileged this is it affect them in the
same way as it will affect more you know
the more more people are working-class I
grew up in in care you know my mom's on
universal credit on a house nest a
Madonna doctor he is I don't have the
well like many people I don't have the
bank of mom and dad to help out when out
when it's needed so it's well not mine
breakfast time is usually the the
quietest time in the house there's nine
of us in here so everybody's asleep in a
minute I feel completely honestly I feel
part of a lost generation a generation
of of young people who have lost the
ability to get their foot on the housing
ladder before their third thing I feel I
feel part of a generation is you know
missed out on the final six months in
education these rites of passage that
you would have have just disappeared
right before your eyes and and the toll
on your mental health it is going to be
pretty vast
a lot of young people are missing out on
things that we take for granted it can
have a huge impact on your mental health
not knowing what you're doing or where
you're going can be really unsettling we
are afraid we are stressed we are not
living our life normally Abood fled the
war in Syria and now has permanent
residency in the UK and this is like
more or less like a war situation many
have compared this pandemic to a war
we're facing an enemy that is invisible
it's more or less the same situation but
like not the same enemy or not the same
reason to drive hello my name is a bhoot
I'm a 27 and I want to have job in film
production for Abood and like many
others the real battle is his future and
the uncertainty it's riddled with for me
when I came here like I was thinking
this is a new beginning for me the thing
now there is a lot of people they are
jobless so I'm one of millions of people
seeking a good opportunity I applied for
delivery and they put me on the waiting
list I've heard it's easy job like they
they accept you like this but now with
this pandemic like they put me on the
waiting list if you're not able to get a
job early on or kind of you know support
yourself in the way that you would like
then there is a scar that opens up there
and it just means statistically those
generations those particular people are
less likely not just for those years but
for the next few decades less likely to
get into the workforce and less likely
to get jobs less likely to earn an
income even the British people they
don't get job easily I'm working hard to
secure this like future but sometimes I
don't know how
yeah they are what's happening in
England alone over 130,000 babies have
been born in lockdown already those
parents weren't expecting their newborns
to enter a world like this Timothy is a
lockdown baby entering a world that is
evolving day by day you almost feel
guilty because you've got this tiny baby
even you've welcomed a new life into
your family at a time where so many
people are losing loved ones no Jessie
thank you so much but you've gained one
yet I had this overwhelming sense of
grief and anger and upset he is just
this this this little ghost and and yeah
I just I worried that when the time
comes for him to be introduced people
would be over his arrival before it's
even started if in for newborn children
what matters is having a safe and stable
place to grow up in inequality of your
childhood experience is a massive issue
that we don't talk about enough and the
Warriors that coronavirus widens that
gulf of inequality even more it's clear
young people need help they need all the
support - whether through the bleak
future they face a lot of young people
are calling on the government to do a
daily briefing but specifically for
young people many of their prospects
have been canned and there are now calls
for a state-led group to guide them
through the tough times ahead we're
calling for a national young person's
task force that would be cross sector
cross issue we're seeing decisions being
made that we're just affecting people
now or in the next three months or in
the next three years but this is gonna
have generational impact the government
told us that while they understand these
are challenging times they won't commit
to creating a specific young people's
national response unit they say they're
doing everything to make sure young
people are not losing out as a result of
the corona virus
when this virus swarmed across Britain
we heard this was an unprecedented time
the truth is no one has ever experienced
anything like this before what is clear
is that young people are struggling
right now and we'll do massively in the
future the most vulnerable in society
would be even more exposed if there's
one thing this coronavirus generation
can do is band together be adaptable and
make allowances the need for that is
greater now than ever before
whilst the impact of coronavirus is
universal its effects are simply not
uniform